love shorty what are you doing
night say hey watching the game smoke us
on but are you all alone
we got 12 bottles of water 56 beers two
vodkas for whiskey six bottles of wine
tequila Nutella cheese steaks a milky
way half ounce Sour Diesel three and a
half grams Grand Master Kush one ounce
of shrooms 15 pills of ecstasy a porno
mag a baseball bat and the video camera
from the movie 27 hours 127 hours Oh an
empty spiral system an empty yeah
nutrient film technique no soil in there
these pipes are filled with hydro clay
it's like an expanded clay aggregate
supports the active capillaries
it's just that in coconut husks we can
believe that [ __ ] no washing no alkaline
in the base totally sterile medium
you're looking at saying generations of
hybridization clumping you're all my
special little children and we feed you
good do don't let me get a nickel bag 15
bucks little man put that [ __ ] in my
hand if that money doesn't show than
your oh me oh me oh my jungle of yeah oh
wee oh wee oh I think I wanna know you
know yah
let me ask you a question what's next
for Jeff's McCall I headed over to
Australia in the Hawaiian internationals
the mimikar gonna wing on over the
London jam with the stones dad says you
have to get up Oh dad said you're gonna
be late again you butthole
wait do you know why there is sunshine
in there because they ain't been fed
their teeth come on chop it chop
moving to a motion all those in favor of
sending our ran down to the gas station
to get some potato chips and chocolate
raise your hand
Oh white trash name yes
Mandy no Marilyn nope
Britney no Tiffany no Candice all right
speed Roxy I'm gonna rattle off some
names when I hit him buzz it okay you
got me yeah all right Brandi had the
chanting Brianna amber Sabrina melody
Dakota Sierra baby crystal Samantha
autumn Ruby Taylor Tyra Tammy Lauren
Shelia tell Kourtney misty Jenni Kristin
Mindy no well she'll be Trina Reba
Cassandra
Mickey Kelsey Shonda Jolene earlene
Claudine savanah Casey dolly Tanger
collie Chloe Devin Emmylou Becky no wait
was it any one of those names with the
Lynne after it yes
I got you for this take it thank you
thank you very much are you employed mr.
Lebowski well let me let me explain
something to you I am NOT mr. Lebowski
you're mr. Lebowski I'm the dude so
that's what you call me you know that or
his dude nasur Deuter or
you know el duderino if you're not into
the whole brevity thing say you're a
Frenchman right yeah I'm so tell me man
has this huge crop of freshmen chicks
like what you gonna end up in jail some
time away so I know that back no that's
what I love about these high school
girls man I get older they stay the same
age